jp morgan is going all in on blockchain
they're claiming they are starting to do
settlements uh with other firms now in
uh using blockchain technology that
they've been developing for the last few
years so we have a tweet here from
blockworks which is a quote from
bloomberg uh saying breaking jp morgan
starts to use blockchain for collateral
settlements in trading and lending so
they've been working on this for a
longer period of time now it's finally
come to fruition and we have their
global head of trading services ben
charles chalice uh who said what we've
achieved is the frictionless transfer of
collateral assets on an instantaneous
basis while blackrock wasn't necessarily
a counterparty they have been heavily
involved since day one and are exploring
use of this technology so this is
something that they have been working in
lockset with jp morgan and blackrock on
on for a number of years now i believe
since 2019 2020 something around there
so call it uh 1224 plus months and it's
finally come out now where they're
starting to use it actually in trading
and lending and it's basically just a
risk-free instantaneous settlement
procedure protocol now that they're
going to be using for trading services
so i think there's a few things here
right uh going all in on on blockchain
is certainly
commendable to some degree but i also
think you need to separate this isn't
bitcoin right they're not buying bitcoin
they're not holding bitcoin they're not
necessarily doing anything with bitcoin
what they're doing is they've created
this protocol now where they're able to
do instantaneous settlement instead of t
plus three or t plus two or t plus one
they can do it instantaneously for free
that transfer of assets with other
counterparties uh it's kind of shocking
i mean there's a lot of nuance behind
the actual settlement system
but i would argue also kind of the the
contrarian view of this is like
blockchains can be helpful in some of
these instances but you don't always
need a blockchain to do some of these
things right like you can build computer
systems and programs that are probably
pretty close to what you can do with the
blockchain without adding a lot of the
complexity that it might be added
because of that so
i don't necessarily know the nuance
behind exactly how they're doing the
settlement process but if you think
about it in the easiest way which is the
settlement might take t plus three which
is which is three days or t plus two two
days or one uh now they're able to do it
free instantaneously with another
counterparty risk free so that's
obviously valuable uh the question would
be like would they be able to do that
without the blockchain i don't know
right this may be just another service
that they're trying to offer to clients
or ease the transaction costs between
their counterparts which is great but i
think the two need to be separated where
this isn't necessarily something that is
uh advantageous to bitcoin or so forth
uh we've been very clear and i think
jamie dimon has been very clear about
their stance on some of these assets
that if clients want all these things
and they're asking for these things they
would obviously offer them to their high
net worth clients but he personally
doesn't own any he personally does not
see the value in it et cetera so we'll
see how that evolves over time but it's
probably a good step regardless that
they're at least testing some of these
things and seeing how they can implement
them in their businesses to improve
their procedures and protocols and
infrastructure because i do think that
there's probably some value that they
can extract from these things but it it
it's uh it's to be determined at what
level they actually do that yeah their
first transaction was on may 20th so a
week ago today right and someone two
entities transacted basically a token
that represented shares of their
blackrock money market fund right so
they were able to kind of move it across
the chain very easily uh it's cool that
they're getting into the technology
jamie dimon has clearly made a stance
that he does not believe in bitcoin so i
think it's very very important to
separate they're looking at blockchain
technologies they are not
from what this is saying they are not
looking at bitcoin they're using
blockchain right um and it's important
to separate those two things uh look if
people are making money the banks uh and
the banks can use technology to get an
advantage they're gonna do it they're
gonna explore it and they're gonna spend
money to kind of do the research and
development of that product right we saw
it with the uh was it the fiber optic
cable from chicago to new york they
spend billions of dollars building one
cable to get literally milliseconds
faster on trading time and information
uh and that's really important i think
people have to understand that like
these companies will spend millions and
billions of dollars to develop
technologies to give them an edge and
that's what i'm seeing that jp morgan's
doing here today yeah i mean look if
you're if you're gonna uh try to find
two counterparties that are the
behemoths in these spaces jp morgan and
blackrock so they're obviously testing
new things they have the capital to go
do that from a research and development
perspective to try to enhance some of
the protocols within their business they
should do that i think that's exactly
what they're doing i do think that the
other side of this though is you can
look at it a few different ways like
some some bitcoin maxis will say this is
blockchain this isn't bitcoin which i
just said right which is the idea of
like don't get it confused but at the
same time it legitimizes some of the use
cases around bitcoin and other things
right because now they're saying oh wait
this blockchain thing like there's
actually probably a pretty good use case
for this that we can use in our everyday
business step two of that is figuring
out you know how it impacts individuals
how they can use it for their clients
how everyday people can pay for things
how it you know uh uh remains payments
like you know there's a million
different things but this opens that
door now where they're legitimizing it
to some step instead of just shutting it
down and saying no this is useless this
is uh fools you know fools are using
this and so forth so again i think it's
going to take time to figure out where
that goes but i don't see it as a
negative it's a step in the right
direction
maybe
maybe